Tony welcome to the show we have you on
because everybody wants to know what is
going on in this tournament why did
Magnus withdraw what is the scoop yeah
you know it's the the little story from
today uh Magnus Carlson did indeed
decide to withdraw after round three of
the singfield cup
um magnus's decision to withdraw from
the event or his personal decisions and
until he makes a public statement on the
matter uh we feel it's best honor his
wishes and and
um we've accepted the fact that he's
withdrawn from the event as well but he
didn't give us any direct reason on why
he did so I think ultimately it's
magnus's decision to come out and give
his reasons I don't want to put words in
his mouth so I'll let him speak on his
own behalf we've noticed that today we
have some Advanced security measures
when it comes to the players tell us a
little bit about that sure I spoke with
Chief tour Arbiter David Sedgwick um
today and um you know the grand chess
tour has prided itself over the past
what five or six years now on on making
sure that we are at the the front
Forefront of the game technologically
with regards to our broadcast and and
with regards to our fair play measures
that we Implement in all of our events
whether that happens to be the Super bet
chess classic in Romania the rapid and
Blitz events in Europe rapid and Blitz
events here in St Louis or even the
singfield cup so these additional
security measures were recommended by
David Sedgwick as yet another way that
we can ensure the Integrity of the game
uh tell us about magnus's future
participations both in the GCC GCT and
the St Louis chess club do you expect
them to be coming back sometime soon
yeah absolutely but you know Magnus made
it very clear to us that this was no
um uh reflection on his opinion of the
chess club in fact I think his tweet
said something about he loves to play in
St Louis
um so yeah we're happy to have him back
as well and and hopefully under better
circumstances well thank you Tony for
joining us and giving us that
information lastly just to confirm
what's going to happen with Magnus
results in the tournament so far great
question so since the um since Magnus
made the decision to withdraw before the
halfway point of the tournament his
results in the previous games will be
annulled and his results against future
opponents the games just won't occur so
it's in essence this is a tournament of
nine players and the results will be out
of out of eight points total so each day
one player whoever would have faced
Magnus will have a buy a zero point buy
for the round and at the end we will see
who the Victor is based out of eight
games absolutely well thank you for
joining us Tony as we seem to be having
a result here in the game between Hans
Neiman and alireza ferrugia they have
drawn their game via threefold
repetition and we hope to have them in
studio for an interview shortly thank
you Tony for joining us my pleasure
thanks Alejandro thank you Tony for
coming out and publicly addressing the
elephant in the room here uh Peter yeah
I it wasn't something that needed needed
to be I needed to be done and uh exactly
thanks once again for uh to the club for
providing Clarity where Clarity is
available and indeed